man it's 2001 and there is so much
tension over afghanistan right now
george bush is threatening to invade but
as leftists we really don't want war so
you should really work on de-escalation
afghanistan we understand you have a
radicalism problem and this really
scares the us fresh after 9 11. so what
you should do now afghanistan is to keep
talking to the us keep george bush
talking listen to him give diplomacy a
chance don't look threatening don't say
anything anti-american give peace a
chance
afghanistan even as u.s troops are
messing on your border clearly preparing
to attack don't stop trying to solve the
conflict diplomatically you have to keep
trying afghanistan what's that the u.s
started this not us oh oh well i well we
we didn't catch that vagueness then we
can barely hear you what's that the u.s
launched the invasion okay first off
it's a special military operation that
only happened because you haven't
extradited osama bin laden i mean the
u.s bombarding your cities and murdering
your people really is an understandable
reaction besides do you have any proof
that the us committed these atrocities
it's more than likely that all the
murder and destruction was done by
afghanis to try and frame the us riding
the wave of this bizarre americaphobic
global sentiment anyway as we said we're
interested in peace above all so now
just let the us finish the job quickly
don't resist and let them plant you
firmly in the u.s fear of influence
where you belong the sooner you give up
afghanistan the sooner the war will be
over thus the sooner will there be peace
in our time because apparently this is
how leftism works